ماريو سوبر ماريو ماريو ماريو ماريو جول
واجه الفقره والمرض صغيرا موهبه كان يتوقع
لها مكانا بين النجوم الصف الاول
لكن عقليته الصعبه والمواقف العنصريه التي
تعرض لها مرارا ابعدته عن المكانه التي
يستحقها في عالم الكره
ماريو بالوتيلي السوبر ماريو نشا في جزيره
صقليه الايطاليه لاسره مهاجره قديمه
في سن صغيره فعرضته على احدى الاسر الثريه
لعجزها عن دفع نفقات علاجه بعد اصابته
بمرض في الامعاء عاش في كان في الايطالي
[موسيقى]
البيولوجيين بسبب تخليهما عنه
موهبته في كره القدم ظهرت في سن الحاديه
عشره بعد انضمامه الى احد الانديه المحليه
وسرعان ما جذب انظار نادي انتر ميلان الذي
تعاقد معه وساعده الى صفوف الفريق الاول
ليلعب برفقه كوكبه من النجوم ويفوز
بالثلاثيه التاريخيه سنه 2010
من العاب الفيديو لصعوبتها
المده التي لبثها في رسميري شابتها بعض
اللحظات السيئه فقد تعرض لعده مواقف
عنصريه في اثناء المباريات وواجه مشكلات
بسبب شخصيته لاستفزازيه وغضبه السريع وقله
انضباطه ما اثار غضب الجمهور وزملائه
والمدرب جوزي مورينيو الذي كان من اكبر
المؤمنين بموهبته انتقل الى نادي مانشستر
سيتي الانجليزي وتالق في البدايه قبل ان
يعود الى معتاده من قبل ويتعارك مع المدرب
روبرتو مانشيني في احدى الحصص التدريبيه
ما ادى الى طرده خارج اسوار النادي سنه
2013 تناقل بعدها بين عده انديه في
انجلترا وفرنسا وتركيا وايطاليا التي عاد
اليها سنه 2019 من بوابه نادي بيريشيا
ليواجهه من جديد العنصريه التي عاناها
طوال حياته حين شبهته بعض الجماهير بالقرد
ماريو لاعب امتلك كل مقومات الابداع
والموهبه
لامه الجميع على سلوكه السيء ومسيرته
الضائعه
اما هو فيحمل المواقف العنصريه التي
واجهها المسؤوليه عن ما وصل اليه
[تصفيق]